Llamé a Dios desde una cabina telefónica
en el desierto de Nevada durante el festival Burning Man.
donde tenía puesta una malla y antiparras de esquí;
y un anciano indio se tendió sobre mí,
y no, no era mi esposo,
sino un perfecto desconocido llamado Paramji,
que le cantaba a mis chakras
valiéndose de la fuerza energética del universo para curar mi "yoni",
palabra sánscrita que significa "vagina".
(Risas)
Iba a mostrar una diapositiva alusiva,
pero me sugirieron
que una diapositiva de mi yoni no sería la mejor idea
en una charla TED, --ni siquiera en TEDWomen--
(Risas)
Al comienzo de mi búsqueda,
también fui a ver al curandero brasileño Juan de Dios
en su centro de atención en Brasil.
Juan de Dios es considerado un médium de trance profundo,
es decir que puede hablar con los muertos.
Pero en este caso, él dice tener el poder de actuar
a través del espíritu de un grupo específico de santos y médicos muertos
para sanar cualquier mal que nos aqueje.
Y aunque Juan de Dios no posee título de médico,
ni siquiera un diploma de educación secundaria,
realiza cirugías
de las verdaderas, con bisturí,
pero sin anestesia.
Sí, ignoro cómo.
También hace cirugías invisibles, sin incisiones,
y cirugías a distancia,
en las que, teóricamente, puede tratar a alguien
que se encuentra a miles de kilómetros
haciendo el procedimiento con una persona conocida por el paciente.
Ahora bien, cuando uno visita a Juan de Dios,
se topa con todo tipo de reglas.
Es un tema complicado,
pero lo más importante cuando uno visita a Juan de Dios
es que se le puede pedir que nos solucione tres cosas,
y él hará que el espíritu de los santos y de los médicos muertos
trabajen en nuestro nombre
para que la tarea se lleve a cabo.
(Risas)
Pues bien, antes de que se rían,
tengan en cuenta que, al menos según su sitio web,
más de 8 millones de personas,
incluyendo a Oprah,
la diosa de la televisión,
han ido a ver a Juan de Dios,
y yo estaba programada de antemano para tener la mente abierta.
Pero, a decir verdad, todo me parecía extraño y sin resultados concluyentes,
y finalmente, volví a casa,
más confundida aun de lo que estaba al principio.
Pero eso no significa que regresé con las manos vacías.
Semanas antes de viajar a Brasil,
comenté de mis planes a algunos amigos
y a un par de colegas de Google,
donde trabajaba como abogada en esa época.
Y se lo habré mencionado a algunas otras personas
de conversadora que soy,
incluido mi vecino,
un tipo que trabaja en la cafetería adonde voy todas las mañanas,
la cajera del supermercado Whole Foods
y una desconocida que se sentó a mi lado en el metro.
A todos les hablé de mi viaje y del motivo que me empujaba
y me ofrecí a llevar tres deseos de cada uno a Brasil,
explicándoles que cualquiera que estuviera con Juan de Dios
podía actuar como representante de otras personas
y ahorrarles el viaje.
Para mi sorpresa, mi bandeja de entrada rebalsó.
Amigos que se lo dijeron a amigos,
y esos amigos aparentemente se lo dijeron a más amigos,
y a otros desconocidos y a gente en las cafeterías,
hasta que en los días previos al viaje a Brasil
fue como si no hubiese quedado nadie sin mi dirección de correo electrónico.
Y entonces, la única conclusión que saqué fue que había ofrecido demasiado
a demasiada gente.
Cuando releí esos mensajes unos años después,
pude ver algo totalmente distinto.
Esos correos tenían tres elementos en común.
El primero fue muy curioso.
Casi todos me enviaron minuciosos detalles de contacto.
Yo les había dicho --o sus amigos les habían dicho--
que, además de la lista con las tres cosas que querían solucionar,
debían mandarme una foto, el nombre y la fecha de nacimiento.
Pero me enviaron el domicilio completo, con número de departamento, código postal,
como si Juan de Dios fuese a visitarlos a la casa
y los fuera a ver en persona o les fuera a enviar un paquete.
Era como si, en el caso altamente improbable de que Juan de Dios
les concediera esos deseos,
simplemente querían asegurarse de que no fuesen entregados
a la persona equivocada o al domicilio equivocado.
Aunque no creyeran,
se cubrían por las dudas.
El segundo componente fue igualmente curioso
pero mucho más modesto.
Casi todos
la desconocida del metro,
el tipo de la cafetería,
el abogado en el vestíbulo,
el judío, el ateo, el musulmán, el católico devoto,
todos pidieron, básicamente, las mismas tres cosas.
En fin, hubo un par de casos aislados y, claro, algunos pidieron dinero.
Pero una vez descartadas lo que fueron, en definitiva, unas pocas anomalías,
las similitudes fueron sorprendentes.
Casi todos pidieron
en primer lugar, buena salud para ellos y para sus familias.
También la inmensa mayoría
pidió felicidad
y por último, amor,
en ese orden:
salud, felicidad, amor.
Algunos pidieron solucionar un tema específico de salud,
pero, a grandes rasgos, pidieron salud en general.
En cuanto a la felicidad,
cada uno pedía algo levemente distinto,
pero todos pidieron el mismo subtipo específico de felicidad, también.
El tipo de felicidad que penetra
y echa raíces en el alma;
el tipo de felicidad que nos sostiene,
aunque estuviéramos a punto de perder todo lo demás.
Y en cuanto al amor,
todos pidieron el tipo de amor romántico,
esa alma gemela que aparece en las novelas épicas románticas,
ese amor que permanecerá a nuestro lado hasta el fin de nuestros días.
Perdón, ese es mi marido.
¡Diablos! Ahora me perdí.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
En definitiva,
todos estos amigos y desconocidos,
independientemente de su origen, raza o religión,
pidieron todos lo mismo,
que eran las mismas cosas que yo quería:
la versión simplificada de las necesidades humanas básicas
clasificadas por científicos sociales como Abraham Maslow y Manfred Max-Neef.
Nadie pidió respuesta a los grandes interrogantes existenciales,
ni una prueba de la existencia de Dios, ni el significado de la vida,
como buscaba yo al principio.
Tampoco habían pedido por el fin de la guerra o del hambre en el mundo.
Aun teniendo la posibilidad de pedir lo que quisieran,
todos pidieron salud, felicidad y amor.
Y había un tercer factor común en esos correos.
Cada mensaje terminaba exactamente de la misma manera.
En lugar de agradecerme por llevar sus deseos hasta Brasil,
todos dijeron:
"Por favor, no se lo digas a nadie".
Y yo decidí contárselo a todo el mundo
(Risas)
desde este escenario,
pero no porque no soy confiable,
sino porque el hecho de tener tanto en común
significa que es importante que escuchemos,
especialmente ahora que hay tantos problemas en el mundo
porque parece que nos empecinamos en marcar nuestras diferencias
y no las cosas que nos unen.
Y les diré que soy la primera en admitir que no soy experta en estadísticas,
y que los datos que les mostré, acumulados en mi bandeja de entrada,
son más anecdóticos que científicos, más cualitativos que cuantitativos.
Cualquiera que trabaja con datos, les dirá
que esta muestra es estadísticamente poco relevante
y demográficamente poco equilibrada.
Sin embargo, me pongo a pensar en esos correos electrónicos
cada vez que reflexiono sobre los prejuicios y los preconceptos
que tuve que enfrentar en mi vida,
o cuando se produce otro crimen por odio o una tragedia sin sentido
que ponen de manifiesto la desalentadora sensación
de que nuestras diferencias parecerían insuperables.
Y luego rescato la evidencia
de que los factores comunes, humildes y unificadores
de nuestra humanidad
revelan que, aunque se nos presente la oportunidad
de pedir lo que fuere,
casi todos queremos las mismas cosas,
y esto es así, sin importar quiénes somos,
cómo se llama nuestro dios,
o qué religión, si la tenemos, nos identifica.
También noto
que, aparentemente, algunos deseamos estas cosas de manera tan intensa,
que enviaríamos un correo a una persona "ninguneada",
a una como yo, espiritualmente confundida,
--algunos dirían confundida de todos modos--
y buscaríamos a esa desconocida para enviarle nuestros deseos más profundos
por si acaso existiera la remota posibilidad
de que alguien que no es un dios --mucho menos nuestro dios--
se los concediera,
alguien que ni siquiera es miembro de la religión que hemos elegido,
alguien que, al ser visto en un papel,
no parecería el candidato ideal para cumplirlos.
Y ahora,
cuando pienso en mi búsqueda espiritual,
aunque no pude encontrar a Dios,
encontré refugio en esto,
aun hoy, en un mundo fragmentado por diferencias religiosas,
étnicas, políticas, filosóficas y raciales,
aun con todas nuestras inconfundibles diferencias,
al final del día
en el plano más básico,
somos todos iguales.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)